Oh
good afternoon my name is Alex I'm from
Berlin and thank you very much Jared and
all the organizers and also Maxine and
John from web directions for having me
here it's a great privilege to be flown
halfway around the world to talk about
things you care about and I I'm still a
bit baffled but yes it's amazing thanks
very much for having you as Jared said I
work on a project called hoodie which I
won't be talking about actually because
I think that as much as I adore hoodie
for how brilliant it is and I think it's
really important but I also think that
the last talk of a talk the conference
it's also kind of special and it should
be about something special and actually
have a larger scope and just you know
one project so yeah this is a talk about
perspectives it's called step office
hurtling machine and it yeah part one
take a step outside yourself so the web
turned 25 not too long ago and I think
it's a good opportunity to take a look
back at its history and I don't mean a
technical history you know with ARPANET
and CERN and everything but the cultural
history where does all the the way we
think come from in this industry and on
the web and this story starts like many
stories start in San Francisco in fact
it starts on the roof of that building
which is the old American Red Cross
building so in the corner of second
mission and the mission district in san
francisco california united states
planet earth and on that roof was a very
surprisingly small antenna and it talked
to a machine that was hovering somewhere
round about where we are looking back
down at the earth a NASA satellite
called 80s three and 80s three had a
couple of jobs so whether experiments
and communications and navigation things
and all sorts of technical stuff but it
also had what you could call the
cultural mission which was the first
full disc photographs of Earth and
that's what it did it took the first
full color photograph of planet Earth
and in this was in 1967 and after almost
20 years of sending cameras into space
this was the first time we purposely
looked back upon ourselves with a truly
new perspective and suddenly there was
this image this cultural artifact that
encompassed that entirety of our species
in our history and back on earth that
made one land very happy and oddly
enough he lived not far away from that
red cross building because everything
happens in San Francisco apparently and
that man was Stewart Brand while on LSD
and 60s he had this idea that a
photograph of Earth could really you
know unify human humanity and give a new
kind of perspective to humans basically
and broaden their consciousness so he
campaigned to have this photo taken and
we sold these buttons all over the
United States and he wrote to NASA and
you've got two politicians in America
and in Soviet Russia he really didn't
care who took the photograph as long as
somebody took the photograph and well as
we saw NASA took the photograph and
since everything they do is public
domain he could use it for basically
anything and yeah he used it for the
first of what I call brands three big
projects and all of these three projects
do resonate with what we do and what we
are today so project one 1968 the whole
earth catalog access to tools for 1968
five dollars now this thing was often
called the Sears catalog for the
counterculture brand and his wife Lois
wanted to list everything you needed to
create a new better society in the in a
commune somewhere in the desert so they
collected useful stuff and basically
they made a shopping catalogue so in
included books about Indian teepees and
growing mushrooms and books on organic
gardening beekeeping and of course books
by Buckminster Fuller on domes and
tensile structures and well so far so
predictable 460 San Francisco I think
but the catalog got more to offer
actually so more books first of all so
psychological reflections the human use
of human beings the ghost in the machine
the year 2000 the futurist modern utopia
jun of course it had you the Green
Revolution and very interestingly groups
under stress and even more books human
bio computer information cybernetics but
maybe most telling of war in this
catalogue of things you would need for a
commune in the desert is that
programmable calculator in the top right
that's a four thousand nine hundred
dollar programmable calculator and in
today's money that's 35,000 australian
dollars that's enough to buy two
volkswagen camper vans back in 60s
california and still have a couple of
hundred dollars left over so what kind
of hippies was this more exactly eighty
percent of the products referenced in
the catalogue workbooks so you had some
things like boobs and shovels but mainly
you had books the catalog wanted to the
tools the catalog wanted to provide
access to weren't necessarily physical
tools they were mostly ideas and big
ideas at that and when I say referenced
it's interesting because the catalog
didn't actually sell anything it was
only an index for distributed objects
and documents and if that sounds
familiar well should be anyway the
catalog became very influential had
profound I opening effect and quite a
lot of people and it's all rather well
too but practically none of them managed
to sustain a successful commune
small-scale politics and groups on
easily solved by a mail-order but lots
of people didn't see the whole of
catalog as a guide to escape modern
society they saw it as a technical
futurist manifesto of a social
reinvention for new interdisciplinary
thinking at a large scale you'll notice
in the index of the catalog the first
thing is understanding whole system's
kind of shows you which direction this
was all meant to go the catalog was
absolutely eye-opening it was a how
things work book for basically
everything was DIY as the new world
order it was a cliff's notes to becoming
a new modern renaissance man massive
environment of the individual through
information and technology its first
line was we are as gods and we might as
well get used to it
and that's a powerful statement but it
still resonates well in the tech world
even today when I was young there was an
amazing publication called the whole
earth catalog which was one of the
Bible's of my generation I was
idealistic and overflowing with meat
tools and great notions that was steve
jobs in 2005 the catalogs legacy is
marrying two seemingly completely
opposed the ideas environmental
conservation and technological progress
and in the 60s you could you could be in
one slider you could be only on the
other side you could be for
technological progress industrialization
capitalism and the man basically or you
could be for sustainability
environmentalism and you could you'd
basically be striving to go back into
the wilderness and now the catalog came
along and said no wait you can have
unbridled technological progress without
about conscience it's possible now
because technology will solve everything
the problem was becoming its own
solution and remember this is sixty San
Francisco this is a time where computers
were seen as a tool of government
oppression and where people went out on
the streets to protest the
computerization of University
bureaucracy you can see at the bottom of
the punch card says do not fold spindle
or mutilate and that sentence became
iconic symbol of tech anxiety in the 60s
and of course they made buttons about it
again
and now the whole earth catalog was
managing to reconcile all this and it
opened up technology for the
counterculture and it opened up the
counterculture for technology now
interestingly xerox palo alto research
center which has everything to do with
what we do do well situated not far away
from where brand lived actually and made
the catalog and for the first couple of
years parks library was exclusively
stocked with books reference in the
catalog Alan Kay worked there and
invented the graphical user interface
which Steve Jobs saw there for the first
time and the rest well it's basically
all descended from there so on to brands
second project 1985 the well by the
early eighties the catalog was long dead
and all the communes may have inspired
as well and fueled by enormous defense
and infrastructure spending in the past
half century California had long since
become the focal point of the tech
industry in the world really hippies
were being replaced by engineers and
hackers it was only a matter of time
till brands ideas and their ideas
collided so a program a friend of his
and I excuse me for that being so tiny
but they've had the same logo.gif since
1985 it's really that big I can't do
anything about it anyway a friend of
brands a man fittingly named brilliant
suggested let's just try again let's
have an online version of the catalog on
brand said wait let's have an online
forum instead but on the same topics and
this launched as a BBS in 1985 and it
really took off and it brought the
remains of the 60s counterculture people
who actually lived in communes brought
it in there and brought it together with
the new hackers and first we got the
well the whole earth electronic link
which is a terrible acronym but a very
good name so it was new about the well
first of all it was fast was much faster
than publishing anything on paper
obviously but at the time that was new
secondly and this should sound extremely
familiar it connected Silicon Valley
people in a social network of tech
professionals so what this meant people
could now switch jobs and products
quickly and easily
is now everyone knew what everyone else
was doing and in a way that is the root
of the startup culture somebody
calculated background that the average
turnaround time in jobs was a hundred
percent of two years so everyone changed
their job every two years on average
some even faster third thing was it was
a gift economy was also new people just
did stuff for each other professionally
and privately and it was kind of an
antithesis to this corporate culture it
wasn't it was a village it was like a
commune people were just you know nice
help each other out private life and
work started merging in a new way or you
had now had an online persona which
incorporated both your your private life
and your work life and you suddenly had
a new social circle that encompassed
both things where before both would have
been relatively cleanly separated and
finally it was a new way of living was
Network constant communal non
hierarchical and merit-based and the
well is actually still around today its
influence on our world really can't be
understated brands third project the
long now foundation so now it's 1996 and
brand is once again seeing that you know
some of the things he helped kicked off
a kind of having adverse effects on the
world and I started thinking about that
he says civilization is revving itself
an empathic logically short attention
span strain might be coming from the
acceleration of Technology the short
horizon perspective of market driven
economics the next election perspective
of democracies all the distractions of
personal multitasking all around the
increase so brand along with a couple of
others created this long now foundation
to increase awareness for the problem
and to foster a mindset of slower but
better and his compatriot Danny Hillis
wrote when I was a child people used to
talk about what happened by the year
2000 for the next 30 years they kept
talking about was going to happen by the
year two thousand and now nobody
mentions the future at all the future
has been shrinking by one year per year
for my entire life I think it's time for
us to start a long-term project that
gets people thinking past the mental
barrier of an ever shortening future
so let's see what we can do end of part
1 I need a drink part 2 no future given
everything I've just said about the
catalogue of the well and along now
let's talk about us on our relationship
to time our industry's technology is
amazingly in flux it changes all the
time stuff becomes obsolete and
deprecated there's new libraries
frameworks languages workflows best
practices preprocessors testing and
deployment infrastructures all the time
stuff changes constantly there's new
stuff every day as so many newsletters
and blogs and people to follow summit
should keep up with and so much to learn
it's more than anyone can remember
really this is chris coiours short list
of resources you should be following as
a web developer presumably a lot of work
went into making it this short and
anyway we're always on a bleeding edge
really it's what defines us and it's
what people pay us for honestly but we
can't stop you can't just get off and
say oh well I've learned enough for just
you know do my thing from now on and
stagnate on a high level can't really do
that it leaves little time for anything
else especially reflection about what
you're doing and we're proud of it I
mean rightfully also because we're proud
of our mental flexibility thinking as we
speak and in a way with the Masters of
making it up as we go along it's kind of
a programming is in a sense but we're so
so stuck in this ever-present now and
our industries culture isn't any better
startups this huge focus on speed and
flexibility on being agile and lean you
can pivot your product you can pivot
pivot your company I mean think about
that you can pivot your entire product
if it's not working out it's crazy you
can fail early you can fail off and it
doesn't really matter it ship it
our prototypes are rapid so we can adapt
and change quickly and in the end
there's acquisitions and sun setting and
everything just vanishes as if nothing
happened amalgam when we make mistakes
we have version control we can roll
things back it's all totally in flux all
the time it seems in fact like there's
little or no value in actually planning
ahead because everything might change at
a moment's notice anywhere and we can
change anything
notice how all that really matters is
this ever-present now and our industry's
content is even worse so Jeremy Keith
last year at brighton's full frontal
conference said that fool that an
average web site is online for a hundred
days three months given that is it
surprising that we're so focused on the
present everything is ephemeral anyway
and we embrace the fleeting nature of
this medium without a conviction because
everything changes all the time forever
and we're forever accelerating and
fragmenting as well so in the beginning
content was a bit like content was in
the offline world you had websites blog
post and then you have micro blogging
then your Twitter the naive snapchat and
by now no doubt you have something
that's even quicker and shorter I'm not
aware of because I'm old I don't know
but this means something we become what
we behold and we shape our tools and
then our tools shape us what have we
shape when have you created constant
flow an endless stream of ephemeral
content accompanied by the constant
panicky fear of missing something we're
always compelled to stay on the crest of
this wave again everything is fast and
we were caught up in microscopic
implementation details and living from
day to day and simply reacting was to
what is happening to us because so much
is happening to us and because the
future is utterly ineffable and we end
up optimizing our creations performance
in milliseconds long to see them vanish
into obscurity through a few months
later so in a way we take no
responsibility because we have no
concept of the future everything
vanishes again anyway we work in to
avoid we do take responsibility and we
do care a lot about the tiny things we
feel we have control over but everything
else just carries us along with it and
we say that once some things on the web
it'll stay forever but barely anything
really lasts
so our perception of time is skewed I
think but that's only half of our
perspective problem so Jim Menlo Park in
Silicon Valley it's where all the tech
people live basically it's near palo
alto it's your Mountain View Cupertino
it's where California's tech industry is
it's where the industry is that
basically dominates the web where
seventy percent of the residents have an
advanced degree I think we're becoming a
bit like a community like fat a bit
increasingly you know incestuous a
little bit detached a bit self
referential I feel it's only natural
especially the self-referential
referential ality bit comes with the
territory I'm willing to bet money that
most software especially open-source
software was made out of the same
motivation personal need scratch your
own itch dogfooding those are fixed
terms in our industry for a reason most
of what we build we build first and
foremost for ourselves and I'm sure sir
tim and only the best intentions when he
implemented the first web server a
quarter century ago at CERN but
fundamentally he was building a tool to
solve his problems and the problems of
his peers nowadays when we build tools
we solve our problems and the problems
of our peers we build tools for web
developers now wonder our two kids are
growing at such ridiculous rates that's
somebody's random grunt file off github
every day we get more and more tools
tailored to address increasingly
specific problems in many cases
inventing those problems in the first
place and at the same time view source
that's vanishing into the developer menu
making the web is becoming a profession
with professionalizing this to it to a
scary degree anything and for an
increasing number of people it's not
going to be this thing we easily
discover on the side where you can be
self-taught and look at other people's
code like i did in probably many of you
it's going to be a career choice view
source even if it still exists i don't
think it helps beginners anymore those
times will be behind us in a way yes our
work is becoming increasingly more
complex and complicated and let people
expect that of us and they pay us for it
makes total sense that our tools and
workflows keep up with that at the same
time we're leaving everyone else behind
I think it requires an empathic leap a
change of perspective to realize that
other people have different needs than
we do and then maybe it's our job as the
people with this power that is our
responsibility on top of a regular job
to accommodate them somehow I think
we've most certainly got an empathy
problem I go so far as to say its
intrinsic to this industry partially
because of how much of our work is this
scratch around each type and we're very
focused on ourselves and people like us
and partially maybe because programming
has always been a bit of an infra
introverts activity if I may further
that cliche I mean we actively outsource
empathy to other people we hire product
designers graphic designers UI and UX
experts and business consultants we hire
them to make empathic connections to
other humans so we don't have to
so we can keep coding because that's
what we do we work with tech and tech
does what we tell it to mostly and
that's a pleasant experience and people
are complicated anyway at the same time
we see the people who make the empathic
connections as inferior in a way we
value their work less than our own
because those are soft goals right and
that's fine somehow in a company or
product context but an open source it
really becomes a problem because an open
source we project our work and to avoid
most of what comes back is from people
who are exactly like us it's not really
everyone's issues is it it's only the
issues of people like us so we're not
only losing our perspective on our place
and time we're also losing our
perspective on a place among other
humans part 3 Hotel California thinking
about the future is hard it's hard as an
individual those for me it is because
I've completely embraced this notion of
that everything changes all the time
forever and that the only viable
strategy for living in life is being
highly adaptable but that makes it hard
to make plans but I think thinking about
the future and group is even more
complicated and we're all in our in our
own little circle here but I suspect
we'd have trouble formulating a vision
of the future web that goes beyond some
open source buzzwords like you know free
open secure private may be decentralized
who knows because thinking about the
future is not only hard it's a bloody
minefield but never actually said that
seriously the thinking about future is
hard he's crop weirdly isn't any way
there are conceptual tools we can use
and I'd like to use one from the
discipline of speculative design so we
can agree that the future is vast and
unknowable but we can narrow down our
idea of how things might turn out by
incrementally iterating through variants
of the future that become increasingly
likely so you start with the present and
then you have this vast scope of things
that up
possible basically any of it narrower
scope of things that are plausible and
an even narrower scope of things that
are probable and then we recall Alan Kay
from Park who said the best way to
predict the future is to invent it and
therefore we have the preferable future
what kind of future do we want for
ourselves now again we're a diverse lot
and probably be a lot of arguments what
we can more easily do than trying to
think about our own future is to
hypothesize about other entities
preferable futures other noteworthy
entities on the web like Google Facebook
Apple Amazon various governments so what
kind of web would they like to have in
20 years and how will they as wealthy
resourceful systems that wish to ensure
their own survival and prosperity make
sure they're still around here's the
future I can see these huge entities
being happy with with a future that's
more closed uncertain all of them will
be completely fine with a more closed
web and some of them will actively
pursue it because in their view closed
ecosystems with vendor lock-in
consolidate different usage patterns
into one provide and promised greater
use of attention because if you can't
leave what you're going to do will stay
a future that is more invasive because
ads are still the main way of making
money on the web services will be
increasingly invasive because the more
they can find out about users the better
they can target ads towards you and make
more money so the latest development is
facebook on android take increasing
liberties in this regard the current
version actually has full access to all
of your text messages why would they
want those so the third aspects of their
prayer for the futures maybe something
like future that is more inaccessible
and laureen transparent the more you
restrict access the more tightly you can
control the experience and prevent users
from leaving your service or using it in
an undesirable way it also makes
monetization easier and i think that
services and devices will start making
choices for you in part because they
don't trust you maybe that's one of the
things one of the reasons why facebook
wants to look at your text messages
maybe they don't trust what you write in
your profile
and they'd like to check for themselves
a future that's more tightly controlled
from governments to corporations
everyone is interested in more control
beard implicit or explicit and for the
tightest control you need not only
completely closed software you also need
completely closed hardware and in that
light it's interesting to look at
Facebook's oculus a closet acquisition
the betting the basically betting a
non-trivial amount of money yet
ultimately insignificant in their scale
of four hundred million dollars in cash
plus 1.6 million what did I say 400 yeah
one no oh god that's a lot of money see
I can't even read it correctly anyway
amazing amounts of money two billion all
in all there basically betting on
virtual reality becoming the nips next
step in content consumption technology
it's a bet that the way we moved from
desktop to mobile will be moving from
mobile to VR in the future don't know if
it's going to happen but will that still
be the web what is going to happen
though is that they want to make sure
that they own and control the hardware
and they want to make sure it runs their
software under their terms and consider
this in the light that these services
are always trying to consolidate use as
many relevant usages as possible unified
into one provider you can already lead a
really involve digital life using only
google products it's convenient and it's
seamless and it's hard to resist because
it's just really well-made and at the
same time in many developing nations
Facebook has become orbit synonymous
with the web there are ethnographic
studies from Trinidad in Kenya that
document her poor people's web users
practically exclusive to Facebook
because it lets them do everything at
the same time at lower costs findings
from our fieldwork suggests that
residents similarly consolidate diverse
activities into a single online platform
now this is from Facebook use in an
informal settlement in Nairobi and
informal settlement as a euphemism for
slum also known as a place where half of
humanity lives and they're using
Facebook it's undoubtedly Facebook
strategy to become more than than just a
website to become just as Google and
Amazon want to be more than a collection
of
I want to be platforms they want to be
ecosystems ecosystems that extend into
the real world with virtual reality and
glass and the self-driving car and that
magical barcode reading wavy stick thing
from amazon that you just wave around
the house and then it restocks your
fridge and glass and all of these
they're perfect examples of manifested
preferable futures they might all fail
but their show is really well what these
people want they want to completely
surround you in their service and be
your main or even only gateway to the
virtual world but the same way bleeding
into the physical world and sometimes
they get help from really unexpected
places here's an Indian telco that's
moving from volume based products where
they charge you per gigabyte to service
based products wait where the cheapest
thing you can get there now is just
facebook and or whatsapp and that's
totally fine for people whose web use is
already consolidated into facebook
that's going to be their web done period
and all of these big players these
stacks they have amazing talent
practically limitless resources and a
strong will for self-preservation if
you're still comparing facebook demise
base and thinking it's going to go away
at some point you're massively under
estimating how aware they are their own
mortality and the lengths they will go
to to survive like paying 19 billion
dollars for whatsapp and oddly enough
there seems to be quite a lot of
optimism about this in in our industry
so here's an ill dash saying we'll fix
these things I don't worry about that
the technology industry like all
industries follow cycles the pendulum is
swinging back to the broad and powering
philosophies that underpin the early
social web and I no longer believe this
these cycles aren't inherently systemic
in my view they happen because there are
people and institutions pulling the
pendulum in their direction knowingly or
unknowingly and this tug of war is
becoming increasingly lopsided most used
websites / country red is google blue is
Facebook that's a bit depressing this
time it's different I think even if you
believe that the open source world can
build an e resist
decentralized secure and private
alternative to that or if you believe
that you know sharing may suddenly
become uncool or you know startup
funding becomes uncool or some major
regulatory action suddenly cripples
these giants there is one almost
geological trend that I don't think
anyone can slow or stop and that's a
trend to the consumer device you can
call the phone or tablet if you like but
its consumer because it's a one-way
thing you can only consume services you
can't create them while the desktop is a
veritable do anything machine and it's
open and your options are basically
unlimited a tablet or a phone is still
an amazingly powerful tool I know people
who basically lead their entire life off
an ipad it works just fine for them but
it is more closed and the form factor
simply does limit what you can do with
it and this is just as true of an open
Firefox phone as it is of a closed
iPhone they are designed for consumption
and not production there's no view
source menu item in there and there's no
view source menu item Google glass and
there won't be one of Facebook's oculus
and there won't be one in any of the
increasingly d materialized devices we
use to access the network the internet
will become more pervasive but less
explicit and visible it will to some
extent blend into the background of all
we do so these consumer devices are a
thing than I fear that our team is
shrinking most people starting with the
web today only know this consumer side
from their consumer device there's a
saying that the entire continent of
Africa is practically mobile only it's
not even mobile first it's mobile only
new web users can't really see it for
what we see it as this wondrous
malleable thing that anyone can shape
don't know its history or its promise if
Facebook is your entire web you're
holding that pendulum to the closed side
and you kind of do anything about it
because you don't know about it the web
has been split into a wedge has been
driven into the web thoroughly and
deeply on the one hand we have the
consumer web with little black boxes and
a black cloud and monolithic stacks
services
it's smooth and it's slick and it's
well-made it's affordable it's easy to
use it's very compelling on the other we
have the professional web where we all
hang out but the web the wedge is still
moving and the more separate the two
parts become I think the more both will
suffer the consumer web because it's
becoming increasingly closed
consolidated access controlled and gate
kept on our side because our side will
simply continually shrink until it's
only a factory to make stuff for the
other half end of part 3 this consumer
web it's closer to TV than it is to our
web now everyone's a channel but apart
from that it's as much a black box as a
TVs Inc ordered a black cloud really
money and time go in and Taemin comes
out and we have no idea or control what
happens in between internet internal
access to this box is reserved for
specially educated people and the
companies they work for and just having
the ability to create content for this
medium doesn't make her mobile devices
much more than many televisions where
our services and content produced and
selected who decides what comes through
and what doesn't access control
filtering and censorship cannon will be
Semak Lee inherent as will surveillance
and we won't even be able to tell
because the system is closed and if all
you have to access the system is your
phone well that's it you can't find out
more right now the internet is headed
towards a highly commercialized
profit-driven opaque and privatized
domain much like the mass media of the
1980s part 4 where did it all go wrong
so we did everything right didn't we we
the web aficionados the open source
community data privacy paladin's we
warned everyone repeatedly over the
years we wrote more secure peer-reviewed
alternatives we even generously gave it
all away for free and yet in the
consumer space open source hasn't
one everyone's using Facebook what the
hell regular people suck why haven't we
already had the year of linux on the
desktop I mean it's clearly superior why
doesn't everyone PGP their emails you
didn't really think they weren't
intercepting everything do you you can
use ab dot net that'll solve all your
problems it's all right there but no
it's not the solution so regular people
aren't the problem right must be the
opposite vent open source sucks ah I
love open source too much to leave that
up there I'm endlessly thankful for all
the time saved and abilities I've gotten
through open source it's practically
exclusive to my side as a developer and
a generally nerdy computer person I
think open source does a lot for many
people but it rarely touches people
outside of our demographic so to make
this more precise open source sucks for
this type of a problem for the problem
of providing good alternatives to the
stacks of building an open free secure
private and ideally properly
decentralized web is why lack of empathy
again we graciously scatter our work on
the earth expecting the unwashed masses
to flock to us take up a half-finished
and often seriously shonky tools and
make a better world with them at the
same time we patronize them for needing
a helper when they can't figure out how
they work that's wrong we took it as
self evident and obvious that people
would even want to participate in this
medium instead of doing the hard work
necessary to make it a welcoming and
rewarding place for the rest of the
world it's just the the cherry on top of
this ice cream sundae of egocentricity
expecting that everyone else would care
about this as deeply as we do they don't
they have other priorities in life oops
I don't know what your first computing
experience was mine was that he wasn't
have been ready on a blue screen or
something in any case if you're my age
it was probably a black prompt and
that's a system with a learning curve
that very closely resembles a brick wall
so to us though for lack of any
alternatives that represents a great
opportunity it's lots of fiddly rubbish
and pain but we saw great opportunities
that's not a majority opinion especially
not today nowadays many people's first
and only computing experience as a phone
and they love it and you shouldn't ever
fault them for it because they're not
lazy and they're not done all they want
is a good experience and they want to be
empowered and that might be hard for us
to understand given our tools and our
history with these super powerful tools
that give us total flexibility at the
price of usability but we can deal with
it because we're used to the pain and we
kind of expect everyone else to go
through the same thing but if we had
have had at if we had had iphones as
alternatives back then i think many of
us wouldn't be here today second problem
believing that technology will save us
all and really this goes all the way
back to the catalog and the well as tech
people we put a lot of faith in
technology it's been good to us we owe
it a lot but just having something that
works for us and then expecting everyone
else to use it that doesn't cut it arab
al can cause a trickle-down technology
so you make stuff for the elite and you
believe that will eventually trickle
down to the masses it's like
trickle-down economics where you make
rich people richer and you think at some
point what's going to arrive at the
bottom so now and just like trickle-down
economics that doesn't work so who
really benefits from our openness it's
other people I guess and it's companies
we employ people like us companies
profits so much from open source
consequently they fund or maintain large
parts of many other big big projects and
again I realize that much of the basic
underlying infrastructure of the web is
open source and that is obviously a
benefit to everyone but again I'm
talking about the places where people
directly interact with software in the
end none of that really helps propagate
the original values of the web you know
this is for everyone not just for web
developers for everyone it doesn't help
fulfill this empowerment promise of the
web it makes us feel good and they leave
and never learnt and helpful yes but
none of all this really reaches people
outside of our circles
and much of this tech evolves over time
often without a clear goal mostly in
reaction to other processes was often
never proactively designed to be usable
it was made to solve a specific problem
and then people just took it and did
things to it and solve other problems
with it and it's always unforeseen
issues and usages we always build in
reaction to a problem or on top of some
exciting tech just for the sake of it
but rarely does any of our building
truly start with a human side and
another aspect of this tech focused
nurses this idea of meritocracy we're so
text entered the main aspect that
matters in a person is their tech output
doesn't matter in a meritocracy it
doesn't matter how awful you are as a
person as long as your code is good but
conversely that means if you write good
code you can be an utter bastard to
people and most of your peers will still
respect you and that's a lousy set of
values and a great deterrent to reaching
more people and it's a huge problem OOP
culture matters it's not just what you
do it's how you do it third thing
hypocrisy do you encrypt all your emails
I don't have you sworn off all
centralized services deleted your
facebook google and twitter accounts
because i haven't I adventure all of you
use Twitter most of you use Facebook and
most of you probably use at least five
Google services a day so how persuasive
does that make us when we speak of the
open and free web how could we really
ever convince anyone that we really
believe in this secure private
decentralized thing our daily behavior
just confirms how important good
experiences are if you can we can't
resist the allure of the big stacks and
the huge companies how can we truly
expect anyone else to they empower us to
to ride them as much as we will the
tools we propagate are often too
inconvenient even for people like us
especially in contrast to the Polish
consumer stuff so seen from the outside
from other people's perspectives who are
not part of the tech industry what what
does this look like that doesn't sound
good
that sounds depressing and it leads it
leads to a super weird schism because on
the one hand you have this amazing
occasionally very altruistic open source
idea which is so cool it regularly
floors people when I tell non tech
people about how it works if there's
wonderful global results-oriented
collaboration and structural agreements
that benefit everyone it's brilliant and
I'd really like to see it in other
realms on the other hand we have a
culture that is often intrinsically
condescending unempowered are too often
straight-out misogynistic so neither
what we make nor how we are was or is
especially attractive to people outside
our peer group to get their hands on
directly culture we have is often
ideologically naive and it ranges from
obtuse and unapproachable to
occasionally plain our style and it's no
wonder that no one cares no wonder they
all go to the highly polished beautiful
services par 5 where do we go from here
tragically we're a bit late to our own
party the consumer web in my opinion
it's a thing and it's going to become
more other thing that's done and I don't
see it going away but we're still
somewhat in control of the other half
professional web and by necessity it's
going to stay open and more accessible
at least technically accessible for
longer culturally low I think it's too
closed I'd much rather we turn it to a
producer web something that's culturally
and socially accessible welcoming and
truly open to all of any skill level of
any language of any gender and that
doesn't necessarily have anything to do
with altruism if we want this open web
we need to populate it with people who
care about it otherwise there's no point
so what can you do
I want to briefly show two things we do
at hoodie so I'm going to talk about
what your tiny bit that we do to
increase accessibility to the technology
we make so very quickly if you haven't
heard of it yet hoodie makes developing
web apps easy and fast it's like jQuery
you include a library it gives a user
authentication data storage sink or five
features and stuff and in development we
have a few concepts that guide how we
make things and i'd like to share two of
those with you the first one is no
back-end building web apps is complex
business especially on the server side
we're dealing with a lot of
technological legacies some a
decades-old all different or acting upon
another it's difficult to get into it's
very easy to get wrong it's daunting if
not outright tutoring to beginners it's
a huge barrier to entry so we looked at
what people wish they could do we saw
that many people want the same basic
things out of web applications they want
to authenticate users they want data
sync they want to send a couple of males
and we thought man these things have
been around forever they really should
be easier what I'm trying to do is
really simple it shouldn't be hard all
computers are just carefully organized
sound everything is hard until somebody
makes it easy and we thought hate web
programmers we have power in this brown
we can do this we can make it easier
it's all arbitrary it's all agreements
between human beings we can agree on new
things so we agreed on this promise
we'll let you build full-featured web
apps from the client side and you don't
have to worry about the back end so we
want to give people a tool that
radically lowers the barrier to entry to
building web apps making it easy to set
up quick to get going and if you can use
jQuery now you can probably build a
simple web app what we're trying to do
is build good tools and make them for
people who aren't us to help us with it
we have a second guiding principle dream
code that's an interface design
philosophy by interface we mean the API
so we're humans interface with our
software
instead of looking at all the technical
features our stack has and thinking
about exposing them somehow we took the
opposite approach again we looked at
what people wish they could do what's
the best and simplest possible way to
for example sign up a new user how far
can you abstract this how simple can you
make it why can't we just do this
account signup you pass it user name and
a password you should be done right it's
2014 and this is such fundamental task
to everything you want to do in the web
why is it still hard why is it not that
simple so we made it that simple and the
implementation may be difficult or it
may be easy it doesn't matter for the
person who uses it what matters is the
experience of using that and so that is
a thing that works and you can do that
immediately there's no backend set up
there's no database schema you create in
your hooding app and you go so what it
is in essence is user centered design
apply to code and not not to visual
interfaces coupled with a bit of our own
preferable futures because everything is
hard until someone makes it easy build
could build good tools for people who
aren't you and remember that technology
isn't enough if we want to change the
web itself to build this free open
secure private and decentralized web we
can either resign ourselves to doing it
in our own realm the pro web or we can
take on the consumer web and try to
compete with the Giants with Facebook
with Google and Apple but we can't win
on the features that aren't important to
us in fact it may well be useful to hide
the things we value most like you know
peer-to-peer encryption decentralized
infrastructure etc because at recent
history is shown nobody cares enough
well even we do we care about the
principles but we don't want to make the
sacrifice we don't want to sacrifice
convenience for security I mean even now
there are still people who make excuses
because they're too lazy to use seat
belts it's the same phenomenon we have
to win through good experience tools and
services we make have to beat what
currently exists on user experience and
convenience and all the auto P&I deals
we want to impose on
the web freedom openness security
decentralization they must be Trojan
horses because they're not selling
points to the average people and too
many of us thing out either and I think
we should provide an upgrade path for
people to move from the consumer web to
the pro web so if you can find ways of
making the workings somewhat accessible
under a beautiful veneer of sensible
defaults and excellent user experience
and so much the better if we can invite
them over that's a good thing because
however of all types has become more
accessible to more people compared to
save the 70s produce a hardware like a
proper PC just the rates of those exist
existing in the world they just haven't
increased at the same rate as mobile but
it's more than they used to be so right
now today we can't see the thing at all
that's going to be the most important
one hundred years from now or even 10
years from now but whatever that thing
is people will have to think it and we
can right now today prepare powerful
ways of thinking for these people we can
build the tools that make it possible to
think the thing and I see this as our
job because we have the power to do it
and with power comes responsibility in
this case because who else is going to
do it and when else's are going to be
done if not now it's our responsibility
we are the people who are setting the
earliest patterns for this medium our
fate won't matter much but the norms we
set will and i don't mean technical
norms neither does he we've seen how
fleeting they can be but currently
there's a vacuum of cultural norms on in
our industry and the web apart from this
Californian ideology we have little to
offer and we can and must do better than
that end of part 5
take a step outside yourself to close
let's look back at that satellite
picture it was the first of three
photographs that deeply influenced
humanity's consciousness for the first
time there was a cultural artifact that
allowed us to see at first glance our
place as part of a natural system we
were no longer the pinnacle of creation
standing above and separate from the
rest of nature now we're hardly even
visible from space we were nature we
were planet inseparably intertwined
photographs helped coalesce an
environmental philosophy the green
movement ecological consciousness
sustainability they helped us understand
ourselves as part of the whole system in
an easily graspable way today we're
similarly it similarly entwined with our
networks and the web as we are with
nature clearly they're not as a crucial
as the plants the provider oxygen but
the networks are becoming increasingly
prevalent spanning the globe bringing
formally dumb objects to life augmenting
our individual bodies and our collective
increasingly cybernetic humanity they've
become a nervous system or externalized
memory and it will only ever grow denser
connecting more people and more things
the network is the ultimate human tool
and it will in time become utterly
inseparable from us we'll take it with
us when we eventually leave other
planets and when it will outlast many of
the company's countries religions and
philosophies we know today the word the
network is never going away again it
will be with us in some form or other
until the very end they will receive
from view as a technical entity but it
will remain there as the invisible
backbone of human society in culture
what I wish for in a way is a cultural
artifact that will easily convey this
notion today that will capture the
beauty and the staggering opportunity of
this human creation that will make
abundantly clear just how intertwined
our fates are it's make clear that it's
worth preserving and improving and
cherishing it's one of the few truly
global species and compressing
accomplishments that has a power to do
so much for so many even if they never
have the power to contribute to it
directly
but to get there we must not only build
great tools we must build a great
culture we will have achieved nothing if
our tools are free open secure private
and decentralized if there is no culture
to embrace and support these values so I
implore you make good decisions now step
off the settling machine thank you very
much